merci Valérie Boyer de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure et lui
dit bougerots donc du groupe les
républicains va longuement parler de la
réforme des retraites évidemment et du
vote de cet article 7 mais d'abord vous
êtes membre également de la délégation
au droit des femmes au Sénat hier
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé dans les
prochains mois un projet de loi de pour
inscrire la liberté des femmes à
recourir à l'IVG il a donc repris la
formulation votée par le Sénat sous
l'impulsion de Philippe Bas c'est une
formulation qui avait d'ailleurs divisé
la majorité sénatoriale est-ce que vous
voterez sexe ce projet de loi quand il
arrive ça dépend comment il va être
rédigé dans quelles conditions alors
parce que aujourd'hui en fait Emmanuel
Macron a un peu fermé le débat
si Emmanuel Macron c'était pas exprimé
hier on aurait pu imaginer que la
formulation du Sénat allait refaire la
navette parce que c'était une
proposition de loi c'est à dire qu'elle
allait repartir à l'Assemblée nationale
revenir au Sénat et qu'on se mettait
d'accord sur un texte après il y avait
deux solutions soit un référendum soit
la réunion du Congrès où il faut obtenir
c'est à dire le Sénat plus l'Assemblée
nationale réunie au Congrès à Versailles
pour modifier la Constitution mais il
faut les trois cinquième et ça aurait
été juste sur ce texte or hier on a
compris deux choses le Parlement est
évincé puisque ça est une initiative
présidentielle donc c'est lui qui
reprend la main avec la formulation qui
reprend celle du Sénat aujourd'hui mais
qu'est-ce qui va en être demain en n'en
sais rien mais surtout il va mettre
l'IVG dans un pack
constitutionnel qu'on ne connaît pas et
donc ça répond vraiment aux inquiétudes
que nous avions je rappelle que en
France personne personne aucune force
politique ne menace l'IVG la seule
menace qui pèse sur l'IVG aujourd'hui
c'est l'effondrement du service public
c'est les difficultés d'accueil des
femmes et de prise en charge ça c'est
une réelle menace mais c'est dans
l'application de cette possibilité
d'avoir recours au nom à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est absolument pas dans la faculté
dans le droit dans la possibilité
d'avoir recours à une IVG d'autant que
le texte a été bien élargi etc donc on a
aujourd'hui une difficulté
supplémentaire qui est posée par
Emmanuel Macron parce que imaginez enfin
vu l'impopularité du président de la
République j'allais dire vu la
préparation des réformes on va y revenir
pour les retraites parce que honnêtement
là on assiste à un texte on voit bien
que rien n'était bien préparé on va
enlever
ça dans un pas constitutionnel on peut
avoir peur que mais ça lanterne
fragilise parce que et pourquoi mélanger
ça avec je sais pas moi l'allongement
durée de du mandat présidentiel la
réforme des territoires enfin on voit ça
n'a aucun sens donc vous demandez voilà
et puis
moi je demande rien du tout parce que ce
droit n'était pas menacé et franchement
voilà alors en plus ça va créer une
autre difficulté imaginons que ce texte
soit soit voté qu'est-ce qui va se
passer alors soit c'est une liberté ok
mais pourquoi réviser la Constitution
pour ça et pas pour le reste je rappelle
quand même que les républicains avaient
demandé une révision de la Constitution
pour renforcer la laïcité en disant nul
ne peut se prévaloir de ses croyances
etc pour donc c'était la formulation de
Philippe Bas et de Bruno Retailleau donc
pourquoi ne pas mettre ça aussi donc ça
va réouvrir un débat donc le fait de
réouvrir un débat ça peut fragiliser le
vote ou alors sur le dos de l'IVG si je
puis dire Emmanuel Macron s'achète un
consensus qu'il est incapable de trouver
ailleurs donc j'avoue que je comprends
pas bien trop la manip
ni au départ parce que c'est une sorte
d'americanisation de la société
et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que le
Parlement est décédé de ce texte tout à
fait clairement puisque c'est à
l'initiative résidentielle donc la balle
est dans le camp d'Emmanuel Macron va
voir ce que ça va donner et on va
évidemment suivre tout ça on parle de la
réforme de retraite puisque les
sénateurs ont donc voté cette mille
articles 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans on va revenir sur les
temps forts de cette séance quelque peu
agitée avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour et Audrey cet article 7 qui
repousse donc l'âge de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans donc était
adopté cette nuit oui après 7 jours de
débat le centre névralgique le cœur de
la réforme a été voté hier à minuit 10
par les sénateurs 201 voix pour 115 voix
contre une trentaine d'abstention un
vote plus partagé que le simple clivage
gauche-droite car on a 115 voix contre
c'est plus que les 91 voies de la gauche
Oriane il y a eu plusieurs absences chez
vos alliés Centris mais aussi au sein
des LR 15 abstentions chez les LR quel
est votre regard là dessus
vous savez ce que je regrette c'est que
on a eu très peu de débats sur le fond
puisque il y a une sorte d'obstruction
cordiale c'est comme ça qu'on l'a nommé
avec des centaines d'articles identiques
on n'a pas pu s'exprimer sur cette
question
ni faire avancer le texte parce que on
voit bien comment un texte évolue hier
il y a quand même deux choses qui sont
passées qui sont importantes on a
amélioré la retraite des pompiers par
exemple on a fait quelque chose pour les
apprentis vous voyez que le débat fait
avancer les choses et malheureusement ce
débat les Français en ont été privés
puisque le Parlement a joué la montre
pour que ce ces articles ne soient pas
adoptés
donc voilà personne n'a envie de faire
une réforme des retraites mais on y est
contraint on y est contraint pourquoi
parce que on a une dette qui est
abyssale 3000 milliards d'euros un
déficit du commerce extérieur 168
milliards d'euros à une des
industrialisation de la France je me
permets d'inviter les téléspectateurs à
regarder l'audition d'Arnaud Montebourg
qui est grainé toutes les entreprises
que nous avons perdu depuis Hollande
Macron c'est quand même ça aussi qui
nous plombe donc
un rapport démographique extrêmement
dégradé je le rappelle au moment où on a
inventé les retraites ou le général de
Gaulle il y avait 6 à 7 actifs pour un
retraité aujourd'hui on en est à virgule
7 demain 1,2 c'est à dire que si on ne
prend pas nos responsabilités
aujourd'hui pour sauver le système pour
faire en sorte que les plus modestes
puissent continuer à avoir leur retraite
les autres ils ont capitalisé donc ils
auront quelque chose et bien le système
s'effondre donc voilà donc bon que nos
collègues aient eu des doutes je
comprenais comprendre je peux le
comprendre
ils expriment ces doutes je suis
convaincue que la nécessité c'est plus
peut-être aussi les conditions du débat
les conditions de la réforme et en plus
on a à ma grande surprise parce que
c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas à ça
de la part des d'isabeth borne je ne
partage pas je fais pas partie de sa
famille de penser politique mais elle
avait la réputation d'être quelqu'un de
très sérieux de très concret etc et là
on arrive dans la précipitation au plus
mauvais moment au moment où il y a de
l'inflation etc avec une réforme qui
n'est pas préparée et qui n'est pas
négocié parce que ça arrive au Sénat
mais je rappelle quand même qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale outre l'extrême
gauche qui a pollué les débats la
majorité présidentielle n'a pas été tenu
non plus
donc ça prouve bien que cette réforme
était mal préparée mal ficelé et ce qui
met
les Français
face à une vocifération contre où on
n'arrive pas à leur expliquer les enjeux
donc voilà où on en est aujourd'hui et
Audrey vous l'avez dit ce vote il a eu
au terme d'une séance tendu oui c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire la séance a
débuté hier à 16h30 avec une quinzaine
de rappels au règlement de la gauche il
faut dire que la veille elle avait tout
simplement quitté l'hémicycle pour
protester contre le rejet d'une centaine
de ces sous amendements jugés irreceva
pour protester aussi contre
l'utilisation de l'article excusez-moi
je me permets de vous interrompre après
170 ou 178 amendements
identiques ou en modifie une virgule en
modifier une heure en modifiant pardon
madame
le sujet y recevable en tout cas par la
commission qui a pris qui a pris 45
minutes pour les pour les examiner
protester aussi contre l'utilisation de
l'article 38 par les sénateurs un outil
du règlement intérieur du Sénat pour
ceux qui ne le connaissent pas qui
permet de réduire drastiquement le
nombre de prises de parole sur un
sous-amendement écoutez la réponse des
sénateurs de gauche je voulais
m'adresser à monsieur le président
Gérard Larcher qu'il m'écoute monsieur
le président Gérard Larcher dans la nuit
d'hier vous avez été davantage le
président DLR que le président du Sénat
en se soumettant en se soumettant à
l'agenda du gouvernement avec cet
article 38 article réclamé par le
président Retailleau et applaudi par les
centristes monsieur le Président Larcher
vous décrébilisez notre institution et
le travail parlementaire
vous l'avez entendu une charge
particulièrement violente du sénateur
communiste Pascal Savoy Delic contre le
président du Sénat et l'ambiance à ce
moment là n'est pas prête de retomber
car quelques minutes plus tard alors que
le Sénat examine enfin les amendements
de l'article 7 dont un pour une sorte de
surcote pour les femmes Bruno Retailleau
le président DLR des Gana nouveau
l'article 38 pour limiter le nombre de
prises de parole
l'obstruction c'est un parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri l'obstruction c'est la
négation du parlementarisme
l'obstruction c'est une prise en otage
d'une minorité sur l'ensemble de
l'institution
si et nous vous nous obliger à recourir
à l'article 38 si chacun est raisonnable
si chacun discute au fond des articles
sans volonté d'obstruction alors oui
chacun pourra jouer le jeu sauf qu'après
une courte nuit une nuit compliquée ou
la gauche a vu tomber un millier de ses
amendements après un coup politique de
la droite on pourra peut-être en
reparler et bien la nouvelle utilisation
de cet article ne passe pas
quand on a un amendement qui porte sur
la question de des bonifications pour
les agents de la fonction publique ou
des majorations de durée d'assurance
pour les femmes du secteur privé même
pas celui-là vous voulez qu'on discute
même pas celui-là un 8 mars mais vous
vous rendez compte ce que vous faites
mais c'est plus c'est plus c'est une
honte
c'est plus c'est plus ce que vous notez
plus l'application du règlement c'est
une volonté délibérée de faire taire
l'opposition par tous les moyens y
compris sur les sujets parce que la
personne va le dire nous expliquer qu'on
est hors sujet que ces contradictoires
qu'on peut pas en parler et tout à
l'heure sur les amendements de Monsieur
Savary on aura le droit de s'exprimer ou
faire comment on fait on fait un mot au
président moi je le président
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous dire
si on aura le droit de s'exprimer je
vous remercie beaucoup de votre
attention c'est ça l'idée c'est de nous
humilier en plus mais c'est pas nous
vous humilier c'est les femmes toutes
les femmes
est-ce que avec l'article 38 la majorité
sénatoriale a humilié la gauche du Sénat
non mais absolument pas d'abord je
voudrais dire sur le plan global aucun
parti n'a le monopole des femmes c'est
insupportable même si on est au
lendemain du 8 mars justement
heureusement qu'il y avait la majorité
sénatoriale heureusement qu'il y avait
Bruno Retailleau et des républicains et
des centristes pour avoir des avancées
qui n'existaient pas dans le texte
d'Elizabeth borne ce qui est quand même
incroyable sur la protection des mers de
famille je ferme cette parenthèse pour
l'instant mais je pense qu'on y
reviendra alors pour la technique
parlementaire vous savez il y a
plusieurs choses qui peuvent être
déclenchées le gouvernement peut
déclencher aussi un article pour
permettre que les débats puissent avoir
lieu mais de façon restreinte
c'est-à-dire un pour un compte sur un
article c'est possible ça c'est pas
humilié c'est pas ne pas discuter mais
c'est examiné justement à respecter tous
les amendements or l'utilisation du
temps de parole par la gauche comme par
crème gauche à l'Assemblée nationale et
bien n'a pas permis justement d'examiner
tous ces amendements et effectivement
et mais bon c'est bon là on a avancé
mais
l'article
l'article 38 qui a été déclenché par le
Sénat c'est à dire une disposition qui
existe dans le règlement intérieur du
Sénat permet quoi et ben il permettait
d'avoir des débats mais restreint
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'avait pas 170
amendements pour changer une virgule
pour changer un jour et en fait pour ne
pas parler du fond parce que c'est ça
qui s'est passé justement et utiliser
notre temps de parole pour faire de
l'obstruction même cordial parce qu'il y
a pas eu de bazar ni de grossièreté et
changer au Sénat et bien c'est pas
correct vis-à-vis des Français on peut
pas leur voler le débat une deuxième
fois et quand il y a pas une
manipulation je rappelle que vous pouvez
amender sur un article mais quand c'est
un sous grandement parce que c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est à dire que la
commission des affaires sociales a
modifié le texte et à sous-amender le
texte ce qui a changé le texte initial
et donc qui a fait tomber les
amendements qui étaient
identiques qui étaient là pour
l'obstruction sur l'article et bien à ce
moment-là quand vous déposez des
amendements sur le sous-amendement ils
doivent être liés au sous amendement si
il parle d'autre chose si par exemple je
ne sais pas vous parler de la retraite
des sapeurs-pompiers et que vous avez un
sous amendement pour parler de la
retraite des artisans et commerçants ça
peut pas fonctionner donc c'est pas du
tout une manipulation c'est une
application du Règlement Intérieur donc
il n'y a eu aucune humiliation aucune
manipulation mais l'utilisation du
règlement intérieur par la majorité
sénatoriale de la même façon qui avait
eu une utilisation du règlement
intérieur par la gauche les écolos etc
pour faire traîner les débats sur la
suite des discussions on en est à
l'article 7 il y a 20 articles dans dans
ce projet là est-ce que vous pensez que
vous allez pouvoir l'examiner jusqu'au
bout et voter dimanche écoutez je
l'espère parce qu'on a des choses très
importantes à voir il faut les petites
pensions la pénibilité la retraite des
mères de famille qui doit être examiné
plus en détail malheureusement on n'aura
pas pu aller aussi loin parce que le
débat nous en a empêché mais je pense
qu'on y reviendra dans un autre texte
etc etc donc il y a plein de choses par
exemple les pensions de reversion pour
les orphelins les pensions de reversion
versées aux personnes handicapées donc
il y a beaucoup de sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants on a déjà passé
le CDI senior ce qui était quand même
aussi une avancée sociale importante et
un gain pour la collectivité donc toutes
ces choses là c'est important qu'on les
débats c'est important qu'on les fasse
avancer vous savez dans tous les textes
on prend des amendements de l'opposition
de la majorité mais le débat
parlementaire ça sert à améliorer le
texte ça sert pas à empêcher le débat
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure on va
parler de toujours de ce sujet on va
continuer à en parler Valérie Boyer on
va parler de la question des femmes dans
cette réforme des retraites pour ça on
va chez vous à Marseille on retrouve les
hauts purgates bonjour Léo merci
beaucoup d'être la président et
directeur éditorial de la Marseillaise
Léo les femmes qui étaient très
mobilisées hier à Marseille à l'occasion
de la Journée des droits des femmes et
elles ont exprimé leurs inquiétudes sur
ce projet de loi de retraite
oui les enquêtes d'opinion nous disent
qu'elles sont très majoritairement
opposées à cette réforme celle qui sont
les plus mobilisés d'entre elles
estiment qu'elles sont doublement de
pénalisées par cette réforme elles l'ont
exprimé très bruyamment hier avec des
manifestations tout au long de la
journée à Marseille notamment et la
question que j'avais envie de poser à la
sénatrice Boyer c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle
a à répondre à ces femmes qui s'estiment
doublement lésées par le texte et puis
par la validation par le Sénat de
l'article 7
alors moi je comprends l'inquiétude des
hommes et des femmes sur ce texte mais
je voudrais souligner une chose qui
n'existait pas dans le projet
d'Elizabeth borne qui n'existait pas
dans le projet de la majorité
présidentielle c'est justement la prise
en compte des maires de famille pourquoi
parce que la retraite et le reflet de la
carrière or on sait très bien que les
femmes décrochent quand elles deviennent
mère de famille et c'est à ce moment-là
qu'elles ont des difficultés pour leur
retraite et des difficultés dans leur
carrière
donc nous ce que nous avons préconisé
c'est que elles aient une surcote de 5%
qui leur permet quand même d'avoir un
bonus important mais on oublie de le
dire que pour
les femmes dès le premier enfant je le
précise pour les femmes qui ont une
famille nombreuse c'est-à-dire trois
enfants et plus elle concerne le
bénéfice des 10% donc ça c'est
extrêmement important
moi je suis convaincue parce que j'ai
déposé un amendement qui a reçu un avis
favorable j'ai demandé un rapport
justement sur cette question pour qu'on
puisse aller plus loin ce que je
regrette c'est que la confusion du débat
ne nous est pas permis sur ce texte là
d'aller plus loin et peut-être
d'améliorer encore ce texte mais je suis
convaincu qu'on y reviendra parce que
lorsque nous aurons des éléments que le
gouvernement a été incapable de nous
donner parce qu'on a quand même
travaillé sans études d'impact
je vous dis encore je suis quand même
très étonnée de ça compte tenu de la
réputation qui précédait d'isabeth borne
et bien à ce moment-là on pourra
probablement revenir et améliorer les
choses donc il faut prendre d'autres
mesures d'impact probablement sur la
question du départ anticipé il en avait
été un peut-être que tu avais été
question on verra ce qui se passera mais
de toute façon déjà la difficulté c'est
que ce texte est un texte restreint il
est restreint par le choix qu'a fait le
gouvernement de passer par le 47 1 c'est
à dire un débat contra c'est pour ça que
la gauche et l'extrême gauche ont joué
l'obstruction pour qu'on débat de passe
ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale et le choix qui a fait le
gouvernement de placer cette réforme
importante et nécessaire contrairement à
ce qu'avait prédendu Emmanuel Macron
dans le projet de financement de la
sécurité sociale personnellement
j'aurais préféré qu'on ait un texte
beaucoup plus global où on parle à la
fois du travail parce que c'est de ça
dont il s'agit c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et notamment pour les maires de
famille qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
dans notre pays pour mettre fin à cette
violence qui s'oppose aux jeunes femmes
qui aujourd'hui doivent choisir entre
travailler et avoir un enfant et vous
alors c'est un choix qui leur appartient
mais vous savez que beaucoup d'entre
elles disent moi j'aurais bien aimé
avoir plus d'enfants mais la société
n'est pas accueillante pour ces femmes
qui choisissent de travailler d'avoir un
enfant donc c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument améliorer une réforme des
retraites ça repose sur un projet projet
global vous savez bien que le rapport
démographique est essentiel et quand
avec François Hollande et Emmanuel
Macron ont détruit la politique
familiale donc on empêche ces femmes de
choisir entre travailler avoir des
enfants elles sont contraintes de
travailler et elle se prive d'avoir les
enfants qu'elle souhaite et autant je
suis partage totalement la liberté d'en
avoir ou pas mais pour celles qui
veulent pourquoi on ne les accompagne
pas mieux pourquoi le quotient familial
est toujours aussi élevé pourquoi toutes
les gardes toutes les aides pour les
gardes d'enfants ont été rabotés
pourquoi le quotient familial a été
explosé sur François Hollande et sous
Emmanuel Macron on voit bien le résultat
aujourd'hui et personne ne parle de
cette violence qui est faite aux jeunes
femmes aujourd'hui il y a moi je
souhaite qu'on en parle qu'on aille plus
loin malheureusement ça a pas pu être
abordé aujourd'hui ça le sera dans la
loi travail et c'est dommage et
effectivement en saucissonnant le projet
comme ça en faisant en sorte qu'on
examine ce texte avec de l'inflation
avec des déficits avec a aucune crise
sociale avec un président de la
République qui avait fait le quoi qu'il
en coûte et qui avait dit que cette
réforme n'était pas utile et nécessaire
je comprends que les Français
comprennent pas c'était pour moi enfin
j'aurais
voulu qu'on est un projet beaucoup plus
global mais on n'a pas le choix et
puisque c'est le gouvernement qui a
choisi à la fois le véhicule législatif
et la façon de l'examiner et puis avec
une majorité que le gouverneur que le
Président de la République ne tient pas
parce que ne rappelons quand même qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale sa majorité et
bien n'a pas été unie derrière ce texte
Léo vous avez une autre question plus
politique
oui justement d'ailleurs on l'entend
dans vos propos madame la sénatrice on
connaît votre intransigeance à l'égard
de la majorité présidentielle des
macronistes à Marseille dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment en soutenant ce texte d'être
tombé dans un piège du président et
d'apparaître désormais comme une
béquille à sa majorité chancelante
d'abord un j'aurai fuite le thème
d'intransigeante je suis dans
l'opposition mais je ne suis pas ni
bornée ni bloqué et quand les choses
vont dans le bon sens je le fais comme
par exemple le rassemblement national
qui a voté le texte pouvoir d'achat on
lui dit pas que c'est la béquille de la
macronie et pourtant il l'a fait
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas dans la
compromission nous avons voté notre
texte
sans le Sénat il n'y aurait pas eu
l'avancée sur les pensions de réversion
il n'y aurait pas eu des mesures pour
les seniors qui sont très et qui vont
leur permettre de travailler dans le
meilleur conditions sans le Sénat il n'y
aurait pas eu des avancées pour les
maires de famille et la liste est longue
donc bien sûr que nous avons dans les
pures qui avaient été imposées par le
Président de la République voter ce
texte vous savez nous sommes
responsables ce qu'on veut pas et ça a
été notre boussole absolue c'est que les
petits retraités se voient privés de
pension parce qu'on est dans une crise
sans précédent avec de l'inflation avec
une dette avec un déficit du commerce
extérieur c'est ça notre sujet merci Léo
on va continuer à parler d'ailleurs je
remercie Léo Léo fraude aussi
excusez-moi un sujet éminemment
important qui est la lutte contre la
fraude sociale le gouvernement
procrastine sur ce sujet qui est
extrêmement important et si on ne remet
pas de la confiance dans le système
comment voulez-vous que les Français
comprennent qu'on réforme retraités
égalité femme homme elle ne lâcheront
rien c'est la Une de La Marseillaise
merci beaucoup léo-pur Gates nous non
plus et on va on va parler d'elle
puisque Léo vous posez la question et
des positions chez les LR qui sont pas
toujours identiques on va écouter
Aurélien Pradier qui a rencontré hier
Laurent Berger pour échanger avec lui on
l'écoute c'était au micro de LCP
ce que nous partageons avec Laurent
Berger à plusieurs c'est le fait que la
durée de cotisation pour nous est plus
importante que la question de l'âge
légal vous partagez ce que dit écoutez
Aurélien Pradier n'est pas la boussole
Dr moi j'aurais préféré que vous
montriez Bruno Retailleau qui lui a
beaucoup d'entre groupes c'est quand
même la moindre des choses ou Éric
ciotique et le président de notre parti
politique
moi ça m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce que le président du
groupe Olivier Marleix à l'Assemblée
nationale propose c'est ce que Bruno
Retailleau propose au Sénat et c'est ce
que Erik sotti le président du parti
propose voilà en dehors de ça si les
gens sentent pas bien dans notre partie
je le comprends je le conçois mais
est-ce qu'à un moment est-ce qu'à un
moment on n'est pas là on n'est pas là
pour commenter ce que font les uns ou
les autres qui moi j'appartiens à la
direction du parti interroger quelqu'un
qui soit à la direction du parti je
pourrais en discuter là c'est pas le cas
mais vous savez très bien que ça pose
même politique
nationale et ça pourrait contraindre le
gouvernement qui peut utiliser le 49 ce
qui pose c'est le problème du
gouvernement il a qu'à tenir sa majorité
aussi ce qui pose un problème politique
c'est de commenter des choses qui n'ont
pas d'intérêt ce qui est intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est comment on va faire en
sorte que la retraite par répartition
sont garanties comment on va faire en
sorte que les Français puissent avoir
leur pension de retraite comment on va
faire en sorte que celle-ci ne soit pas
diminuée parce que c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est soit on diminue les pensions en
restant comme ça et on appauvrit les
Français je rappelle quand même qu'en
France le niveau des pensions est tel
que les retraités français sont moins
pauvres que leur enfin ont une meilleure
situation que leurs voisins européens
c'est ça qu'on veut maintenir voilà
maintenant les commentaires les crises
existentielles des uns et des autres qui
font tout pour exister je regrette que
vous prêtiez à ce genre de choses qui
nous empêche de discuter du fond on en a
beaucoup parlé pendant 25 minutes merci
beaucoup merci vous reviendrez nous voir
très vite puisque vous le prochain
projet de loi c'est le projet de
l'immigration et évidemment c'est un
sujet aussi sur lequel vous travaillez
on en parlera très vite avec vous merci
Valérie d'avoir été